[Music]
under the light of the summer moon the
waters of the Gulf of Mexico in the
Caribbean Sea produce one of the most
extraordinary explosions of life on the
planet
[Music]
with a ballet like precision brain and
star corals released millions of eggs
that float to the surface like luminous
pearls from the dark depths of the sea
[Music]
within minutes smoky cloud of sperm
follows
each species of coral has its own moment
to find a mate
when the waters warm currents gentlemen
and moon just right should the
conditions be less than perfect some
calm could delay spawning for almost a
month but if all goes well the
fertilized eggs will develop and
eventually contribute to building a new
reef the moon also triggers the spawning
of dog and Camaro snappers they gather
of great masses forming a column or
cyclone a fish that spins up toward the
surface light
[Music]
in a mating ritual Kerber of females
hang upside down and turn right to
attract males a single female can
deposit tens of thousands of eggs a
night but only a lucky few survive
[Music]
the abundance of fishings is good news
for whale sharks who come here to feast
on Kuvera
caviar
the mating rituals of the Kerberos
snappers have nothing though on squid
they compete for the attentions of a
female with a display ever-changing
color their cousins are hunted by sperm
whales who dive into bone crushing
depths to catch them
the whales need the nourishment
particularly when nursing their newborn
calves for the Yellowhead Jawfish
reproduction is a little different after
successfully mating the male is left in
do many eggs and holds them in his mouth
for five days until they finally hatch
lured by the same mix of the Moon and
Italians in the temperatures nurse
sharks carry out an elaborate mating
dance spinning and twisting in a frenzy
of movement
their shirts can give birth to litters
of as many as 20 to 25 pups life is rich
productive in warm waters of the reef
systems of Gulf Caribbean waters
but it's an ecosystem in danger human
activity has caused the disappearance of
80% of the hard coral cover of reefs
agricultural runoff has created dead
sets in the Gulf of Mexico with oxygen
levels too low to support life
three my fear is in trouble but there's
still hope with care and protection the
health of these orders can be restored